All right, guys, so in this video, we're going to talk about balanced price range.
Basically, it is another entry pattern that we use with Fair Value Gap.
And what it does is it makes the Fair Value Gap even stronger.
So let's assume that you have a Fair Value Gap here.
And if we have BPR here as well, there are much more chances that that Fair Value Gap is
going to hold the trade and it's going to go into your direction.
Now, it's not necessary to always look for BPR, but, you know, it could be a nice
confluence and it is also a nice entry pattern that you can use.
So what is a BPR?
So let's assume that you have a push, a move to the down, right?
Boom.
So let's assume there was some liquidity sweep right here.
And after that, you have a market structure shift right here.
Now, you look at the extreme Fair Value Gap, which is right here, right?
And look at the left.
So there is Fair Value Gap here as well, right?
So you are looking at this Fair Value Gap, but if you look at to the left, the move
that took out liquidity, now it necessarily don't have to be the move that takes out
liquidity.
I'm just, I'm just showing it as an example.
But when you have a move and then you have a market structure shift, look at the last
move before market structure shift and look at here.
If there is Fair Value Gap here and there is Fair Value Gap in the new move that
broke the market structure and the old Fair Value Gap and the new Fair Value
Gap is overlapping with each other.
If that is happening, then that area becomes BPR.
Okay.
And when price comes back into this area, it's going to push up.
So let me explain this again.
Do you see this move right here?
Let me remove this to clear confusion, right?
You have a move up.
So let's assume you have lower low, lower high, sorry, lower low, lower high, lower low.
And this lower low gets broken with market structure shift.
And this is extreme Fair Value Gap.
Now, normally you would enter from this extreme Fair Value Gap right here.
But look to the left of this extreme Fair Value Gap.
That's right here.
If there is Fair Value Gap here as well, you know, and price does not respect the old
Fair Value Gap and it pushes through this level, breaking market structure or shifting
the market structure and also leaving the Fair Value Gap that overlaps with the
previous Fair Value Gap, then that level becomes balanced price range.
I hope I explained it well.
And what I'm going to show you examples is going to be clear.
So let me show you example number one.
So you see you have lower low, lower high, lower low, and then you have a market structure shift.
Look at here.
Do you see this Fair Value Gap right here?
From here to here.
What happened is price did not respect this old Fair Value Gap.
And what happened is price went back up and did market structure shift.
Okay.
Now, look at this, this Fair Value Gap is way too big.
It's just way too big.
So if you take your entry from the here, your stop loss is going to be huge.
But if you look at here, you have BPR and the new Fair Value Gap is overlapping with the old Fair Value Gap.
So in this case, what you can do is you can take your entry from the BPR or old Fair Value Gap.
Okay.
So essentially, what is happening here is that the old Fair Value Gap,
instead of acting as a resistance level, when it is broken, it is not reacting as a support level,
the old Fair Value Gap.
And also, if there is new Fair Value Gap that is overlapping with the old Fair Value Gap,
then that level becomes BPR.
And trust me, that move is going to be big if your whole model was perfect.
So you can see Fair Value BPR right here, it overlaps.
And what I mean by overlap is it must have some part of Fair Value Gap between this box.
So you see this box that I've drawn, you draw the box from the BPR, right?
The old Fair Value Gap, you drag it along.
And if any part of the Fair Value Gap, even a tiny bit is in that level, in this box,
then you can take your entry from BPR.
Let me show you another example.
Right here.
Okay.
So you can see right here.
So you have a market structure shift, right?
Big.
And before market structure shift, we had this BPR right here.
You see this old Fair Value Gap, boom, boom, boom, boom, right?
And price did not respect this level.
It just went down data market structure shift.
Now the old Fair Value Gap, right?
And this new Fair Value Gap.
So this is the new Fair Value Gap, whoa, whoa, right?
And this right here, womb and womb.
So you drag the box along.
It is overlapping with the old Fair Value Gap.
This is the old Fair Value Gap, boom, boom.
This is the new Fair Value Gap, boom, boom.
You draw the box from the old Fair Value Gap, boom, boom.
Drag it along.
If the new Fair Value Gap is overlapping, it has some sort of part in the old Fair Value Gap box that I've drawn.
Then you can take your entry from that box.
So you can see you have your Fair Value Gap right here.
If you took your entry from this Fair Value Gap, price went down,
and you move your store blocks to break even.
But what happened is then price came back, filled the BPR level,
and then pushed down to its original destination.
So I hope this video was clear, guys.
If you did not understand this, make sure you watch it again.
And again, I tried my best to explain this.
I hope you guys understood it well.
Let's move on to the next video.